anable is a powerful automation tool
used to manage and configure computer
systems it's important because it
streamlines task improv scalability and
supports infrastructure as code saving
time and resources jobs related to
anible include anible administrator
devops engineer system administrator
Cloud engineer and network engineer
salaries vary but can range from $60,000
to
$150,000 and above per year depending on
the role and location if you are looking
to learn anable then check the wide
range of devops courses from Simply
learn in collaboration with Top Notch
universities across the globe with these
devops courses you will learn the
essential tools Us in devops like
terraform Maven anible Jenkins
kubernetes Docker and much more to
enroll into these courses one year of
experience is preferred so hurry up and
enroll Now find the ca Link in the
description box so before we move ahead
in this video consider subscribing to
Simply learn and hit the Bell icon to
never miss any updates from us over to
our tutors this is Matthew from Simply
learn and we're going to be covering
anable today as one of the key tools
that you would have within your Dev Ops
environment so the things that we're
going to go through today is we're going
to cover why you would want to use a
product like anore what anible really is
and how it's of value to you in your
organization the differences between
anible and other products that are
similar to it on the market and what
makes anible a compelling product and
then we're going to dig into the
architecture for anible we're going to
look at how you would create a Playbook
how you would manage your inventory of
your server environments and then what
is the actual workings of anable as a
little extra we're going to also throw
in anible Tower one of the secret Source
solutions that you can use for improving
this Speed and Performance of how you
create your anible environments and
finally we're going to go through a use
Case by looking at hoot Suite social
media management company and how they
use anible to really improve the
efficiency within their organizations so
let's jump into this so the big question
is why anable so you have to think of
anable as another tool that you have
within your Dev Ops environment for
helping manage the servers and this
definitely fall on the operations side
of the dev Ops equation so if we look
here we have a picture of Sam and like
yourselves Sam is a system administrator
and he is responsible for maintaining
the infrastructure for all the different
servers within his company so some of
the servers that he may have that he has
to maintain could be web servers running
Apache it could be database servers
running MySQL and if you only have a few
servers then that's fairly easy to
maintain I mean if you have three web
servers and two database servers and
let's face it wouldn't we all love just
to have one or two servers to manage it
would be really easy to maintain the
trick however is as we start increasing
the number of servers and this is a
reality of the environments that we live
and operate in it becomes increasingly
difficult to create consistent setup of
different infrastructures such as web
servers and databases for the simple
reason that we're all human as if we had
to update and maintain all of those
servers by hand there's a good chance
that we would not set up each server
identically now this is where ANP really
comes to the rescue and helps you become
an efficient operations team anable like
other system Solutions such as chef and
puppet uses code that you can write and
describe the installation and setup of
your servers so you can actually repeat
it and deploy those servers consistently
in into multiple areas so now you don't
have to have one person redoing and
reowing setup procedures you just write
one script and then each script can be
executed and have a consistent
environment so we've gone through why
you'd want to use anible let's step
through what anible really is so you
know this is all great but you know how
do we actually use these tools in our
environment so anable is a tool that
really allows you to create and control
three key areas that you would have
within your operations environment first
of all there's it automation so you can
actually write instructions that
automate the it setup that you would
typically do manually in the past the
second is the configuration and having
consistent configuration imagine setting
up hundreds of Apache servers and being
able to guarantee with Precision that
each of those Apache servers is set up
identically and then finally you want to
be able to automate the deployment so
that as you scale up your server
environment you can just push out
instructions that can deploy
automatically different servers the
bottom line is you want to be able to
speed up and make your operations team
more efficient so let's talk a little
bit about pull configuration and how it
works with anable so there are two
different ways of being able to set up
uh different environments for server
farms uh one is to have a key server
that has all the instructions on and
then on each of the servers that connect
to that main Master server you would
have a piece of software known as a
client installed on each of those
servers that would communicate to the
main Master server and then would
periodically either update or change the
configuration of the slave server this
is known as a pull configuration an
alternative is a a push configuration
and the push configuration is slightly
different the main difference is as with
a pull configuration you have a master
server where you actually put up the
instructions but unlike the pull
configuration where you have a client
installed on each of the services with a
push configuration you actually have no
client installed on the remote servers
you simply are pushing out the
configuration to those servers and
forcing a restructure or a fresh clean
installation in that environment so
anible is one of those second
environments where it's a push
configuration server and this contrasts
with other popular products like chef
and puppet which have a Master Slave um
architecture with a master server
connecting with a client on a remote
slave environment where you would then
be pushing out the updates with anal
you're pushing out the service and the
structure of the server to remote
hardware and you are just putting it
onto the hardware irrelevant of the
structure that's out there and there are
some significant advantages that you
have in that in that you're not having
to have the extra overhead weight of a
client installed on those remote servers
having to constantly communicate back to
the master environment so let's step
through the architecture that you would
have for an anible environment so when
you're setting up an anible environment
the first thing you want to do is have a
local machine and the local machine is
where you're going to have all of your
instruction and really the power of the
control that you'd be pushing out to the
remote server so the local machine is
where you're going to be starting and
doing all of your work connected from
the local machine are all the different
nodes pushing out the different
configurations that you would set up on
the local machine the configurations
that you would write and you would write
those in code are within a module so you
do this on your local machine for
creating these modules and each of these
modules is actually consistent playbooks
the local machine also has a second job
and that job is to manage the inventory
of the nodes that you have in your
environment the local machine is able to
connect to each of the different nodes
that you would have in your Hardware
Network through SSH clients so a secure
client let's dig into some of the
different elements within that
architecture and we're going to take a
first look at playbooks that you would
write and create for the anable
environments so so the core of anle is
the Playbook this is where you create
the instructions that you write to
define the architecture of your Hardware
so the Playbook is really just a set of
instructions that configure the
different nodes that you have and each
of those set of instructions is written
in a language called yaml and this is a
standard language used for configuration
server environments did you know that
yaml actually stands for yaml a markup
language let's just a little tidbit to
hide behind your ear so let's have a
look at one of these playbooks it looks
like and here we have a sample uh yamamo
script that we've written so you start
off your yamama script with three dashes
and that indicates the start of a script
and then the script itself is actually
consistent of two distinct plays at the
top we have play one and below that we
have play two within each of those plays
we Define which nodes are we tying in so
here we have a web server in the top
play and in the second play we have a
database server that we're targeting and
then within each of those server
environments we have the specific tasks
that we're looking to execute so let's
step through some of these tasks we have
an install patchy task we have a starter
patchy task and we have an install MySQL
task and when we do that we're going to
execute a specific set of instructions
and those instructions can include
installing Apache and then setting the
state of the Apache environment or
starting the Apache environment and
setting up and running the MySQL
environment so this really isn't too
complicated and that's the really good
thing about working with ymo is it's
really designed to make it easy for you
as an operations lead to be able to
configure the environments that you want
to consistently create so let's take a
step back though we have two hosts we
have web server and datab Bas server
where do these names come from well this
takes us into our next stage and the
second part of working with anable which
is the inventory management part of
anible so the inventory part of anible
is where we maintain the structure of
our Network environment so what we do
here is part of the structure and
creating different nodes is we've had to
create two different nodes here we have
a web server node and a database server
node and under web Ser node we actually
have the names that we actually pointing
to specific machines within that
environment so now when we actually
write our scripts all we have to do is
refer to either web server or database
server and the different servers will
have the instructions from the yamas
script executed on them this makes it
really easy for you to be able to just
point to new services without having to
write out complex instructions so let's
have a look look at how anible actually
works in real world so the real world
environment is that you would have the
ansible software installed in a local
machine and then it connects to
different nodes within your network on
the local machine you'll have your first
your playbook which is the set of
instructions for how to set up the
remote nodes and then to identify how
you're going to connect to those nodes
you'll have an inventory we use secure
SSH connections to to each of the
servers so we are encrypting the
communication to those servers we're
able to grab some basic facts on each
server so we understand how we can then
push out the Playbook to each server and
configure that server remotely the end
goal is to have an environment that is
consistent so this ask you a simple
question what are the major
opportunities that anable has over chef
and puppet really like to hear your
answers in the comments below pop them
in there and we'll get back to you and
really want to hear how you feel that
anible is a stronger product or maybe
you think it's a weaker product as it
compares to other similar products in
the market here's the bonus we're going
to talk a little bit about anible Tower
so anible Tower is an extra product that
red hat created that really kind of puts
the cherry on the top of the ice cream
or is the icing on on your cake anible
by itself is a commandline tool however
anable Tower is a framework that was
designed to access anible and through
the anible tower framework we now have
an easyto use guei this really makes it
easy for non-developers to be able to
create the environment that they want to
be able to manage in their devops plan
without having to constantly work with
the command prompt window so so instead
of opening up terminal window or command
window and writing out complex
instructions only in text you can now
use drag and drop and mouse click
actions to be able to create your
appropriate playbooks inventories and
pushes for your nodes all right so we've
talked a lot about anel let's take a
look at a specific company that's using
anel today and in this example we're
going to look at hoot Suite now hoot
Suite if you've not already used that
products and they have a great product
hoot is a social media management system
they are able to help with you managing
your pushes of social media content
across all of the popular social media
platforms they're able to provide the
analytics they're able to provide the
tools that marketing and sales teams can
use to be able to assess a sentiment
analysis of the messages that are being
pushed out really great tool and very
popular
but part of their popularity drove a
specific problem straight to hoot Suite
the challenge they had at hotu is that
they had to constantly go back and
rebuild their server environment and
they couldn't do this continuously and
be consistent there was no standard
documentation and they had to rely on
pure memory to be able to do this
consistently imagine how complex this
could get as you're scaling up with a
popular product that now has tens of
thousands to hundreds of thousands of
users this is where ano what came in and
really helped the folks over at
HootSuite today the devops team at
HootSuite write out playbooks that have
Specific Instructions that Define the
architecture and structure of their
Hardware nodes and environments and are
able to do that as a standard product
instead of it being a problem in scaling
up their environment they now are able
to rebuild and create new servers in a
matter of seconds the bottom line is
anible has been able to provide hoot
Suite with it automation consistent
configuration and free out time from the
operations team so that instead of
managing servers they're able to provide
additional new value to the company
anible provides you with one of the
easiest ways to automate your
application and it infrastructure on
that that note hi guys welcome to this
complete anible tutorial by simply learn
in this video we'll be covering some of
the most important Concepts relating to
the devops tool anible we'll take you
through how you can install anible and
how you can use the tool to automate
your processes first we have anel to
tell us how to install anible on your
system a very warm welcome to all our
viewers I'm Angelie from Simply learn
and today I'll be showing you how you
can install the configuration management
tool and sible so let's have a brief
about why one would use anable and what
exactly is anable so if you consider the
case of an organization it has a very
large infrastructure which means it has
more than probably hundreds of systems
and giving one or even a small team of
people the responsibility to configure
all these systems makes their work
really tough repetitive and as you know
manual work is always prone to errors so
anible is a tool which can automate the
configuration of all these systems with
anible a small team of system system
administrators can write simple codes in
gaml and these codes are deployed onto
the hundreds and thousands of servers
which configures them to the desired
States so Anil automates configuration
management that is configuring your
systems it automates orchestration which
means it brings together a number of
applications and decides an order in
which these are executed and it also
automates deployment of the applications
now that we know what answers does let's
move on to the installation of anible so
here is my Oracle VM virtual box manager
I'll be using two systems there's the
note system which is basically my client
system and there's the server system or
the Master System so let's begin at our
server
system so this is my Master System guys
so the first thing we do is we download
our anable
tool so one thing we must remember with
anable is that unlike Chef or puppet
anible is a push type of configuration
management tool so what this means is
that the entire control here lies with
your master or your server system this
is where you write your configuration
files and these are also responsible for
pushing these configuration files onto
your node or client system as in when
required great so anible tool is
installed now we need to open an anible
host file and there we'll specify the
details of our node or client
machine so this is the anable host file
as you can see here the entire file is
commented but there's a certain syntax
that You' observe for example here we
have a group name web servers under
which we have the IP addresses or
certain host name so this is about how
we'll be adding the details for our our
client system first we need to give a
group
name under this group basically we add
all the clients which require a certain
type of configuration since we are using
just one node we'll give only the
details for that particular node first
we need to add the IP address of our
client machine so let's just go back to
our client
machine and this here is the IP address
192.168
2.11 once you have typed in your IP
address give a space and then we'll
specify the user for our client
machine so all Communications between
the server or the Master System and the
client or the node system takes place
through SSH ssh basically provides a
secure channel for the transfer of
information follow this up with your
password in my case it's the roots
password and that's it we are done so
now we save this file and go back to our
terminal so now that our host file is
written the next thing we do is we write
our Playbook so Playbook is the
technical term used for all the
configuration files that we write in
anible now playbooks are written in yaml
yaml is extremely simple to both write
and understand it's in fact very close
to
English so now we'll write our Playbook
The Playbook or any code in yaml first
starts with three dashes this indicates
the beginning of your file next thing we
need to give a name to our Playbook so
name and I'm going to name my playbook
sample book we next need to specify our
host systems which is basically the
systems at which the configuration file
or the playbook in our case will be
executed so we'll be executing this at
the client machines mentioned under the
group anable servers so we had just one
cent machine under it we'll still
mention the group
name we next need to specify the
username with which we'll be logging
into our client machine which is Root in
my case and become true specifies that
you need to become the root to execute
this Playbook so becoming the roots
called a privilege escalation next we
need to specify our task so these are
basically the actions that the Playbook
will be performing so you would have
noticed every so far is aligned that is
name host remote user become and task
because these are at one level now
whatever comes under task will be
shifted slightly towards the right
although yaml is extremely simple to
understand and read both it's a little
tricky while writing because you need to
be very careful about the indentations
and the
spacing so my first task is install
httpd which is basically a Apache server
so now my command yum and this will be
installing the httpd
package and the latest statee of it will
be installed so that's our first task
now our second task would be running our
Apache service so name run
httpd and the action which is
service will be performed on httpd hence
the name
httpd and state must be started now we
come to our third
task so here we'll create a very simple
web page that will be
hosted so create content is the name of
our
task and the content that we are
creating here will basically be copied
to our node system at a particular file
location that we'll
provide our content will be
congrats and then we'll provide the
destination at which this file will be
copied
so this is the default location for all
our HTML
files and that's it we are done writing
our Playbook just save this and go back
to your
terminal before we execute the Playbook
or push the Playbook onto our node
system let's check the syntax of our
Playbook so the command for doing so
is and if everything's fine with your
playbook the output would be just your
playbook name so our syntax is perfectly
fine now we can push on the Playbook to
our node or the client
machine and that's the Syntax for doing
so now as your playbook is being sent
over to the client machine you can see
that first the facts are gathered that
is the current state of your client
machine is first fetched to check what
all is to be changed and what is already
present so the first thing is installing
httpd so our system already had httpd so
it says okay because this does not need
to be changed our next task was running
httpd now Although our system had the
Apache service it was not running so
that is one thing that was changed the
next was there was no content available
so the content was also added so two
tasks were changed and four things were
okay now everything seems fine and
before you move any forward it is very
important that you check this one line
of documentation provided by anel you
have all kind of information available
here regarding which all tasks were
executed if your client machine was
reachable or unreachable and so on so
now that everything's fine here we can
move on to our note system and we'll
just go to our browser so if our
Playbook has been executed here what
should happen is that the httpd service
must be in the running State and the web
page that we created should be hosted so
let's just type Local Host and great
everything's working fine so our web
page page is displayed here so we come
to an end for our installation and
configuration video for the
configuration management tool anible if
you have any doubts please post them in
the comment section below and we'll
definitely get back to you as soon as
possible thanks Angelie now we have
Matthew and Angie to take us through how
to work with anible anible today as one
of the key tools that you would have
within your Dev Ops environment so the
things that we're going to go through
today is we're going to cover why you
would want to use a product like ano
what anible really is and how it's of
value to you in your organization the
differences between anible and other
products that are similar to it on the
market and what makes anible a
compelling product and then we're going
to dig into the architecture for anable
we're going to look at how you would
create a Playbook how You' manage your
inventory of your server environments
and then what is the actual workings of
anable as a little extra we're going to
also throw in anible Tower one of the
secret Source solutions that you can use
for improving the the Speed and
Performance of how you create your
anible environments and finally we're
going to go through a use Case by
looking at hoot Suite social media
management company and how they use
anible to really improve the efficiency
within their organizations so let's jump
into this so the big question is why
anable so you have to think of anable as
another tool that you have within your
Dev Ops environment for helping manage
the service and this definitely F on the
operations sides of the dev Ops equation
so if we look here we have a picture of
Sam and like yourselves Sam is a system
administrator and he is responsible for
maintaining the infrastructure for all
the different servers within his company
so some of the servers that he may have
that he has to maintain could be web
servers running Apache it could be
database servers running MySQL and if
you only have a few servers then that's
fairly easy to maintain I mean if you
have three web servers and two database
servers and let's face it wouldn't we
all love just to have one or two servers
to manage it would be really easy to
maintain the trick however is as we
start increasing the number of servers
and this is a reality of the
environments that we live and operate in
it becomes increasingly difficult to
create consistent setup of different
infrastructures such as web servers and
databases for the simple reason that
we're all human as if we had to update
and maintain all of those servers by
hand there's a good chance that we would
not set up each server identically now
this is where anible really comes to the
rescue and helps you become an efficient
operations team anible like other system
Solutions such as chef and puppet uses
code that you can write and describe the
installation and set up of your servers
so you can actually repeat it and deploy
those servers consistently into multiple
areas so now you don't have to have one
person redoing and reowing setup
procedures you just write one script and
then each script can be executed and
have a consistent environment so we've
gone through why you'd want to use
anible let's step through what anible
really is so you know this is all great
but you know how do we actually use
these tools in our environment so anible
is a tool that really allows you to
create create and control three key
areas that you would have within your
operations environment first of all
there's it automation so you can
actually write instructions that
automate the it setup that you would
typically do manually in the past the
second is the configuration and having
consistent configuration imagine setting
up hundreds of Apache servers and being
able to guarante with Precision that
each of those Apache servers is set up
identically and then and then finally
you want to be able to automate the
deployment so that as you scale up your
server environment you can just push out
instructions that can deploy
automatically different servers the
bottom line is you want to be able to
speed up and make your operations team
more efficient so let's talk a little
bit about pull configuration and how it
works with anable so there are two
different ways of being able to set up
uh different environments for Server
farms uh one is to have a key server
that has all the instructions on and
then on each of the servers that connect
to that main Master server you would
have a piece of software known as a
client installed on each of those
servers that would communicate to the
main Master server and then would
periodically either update or change the
configuration of the slave server this
is known as a pull configuration an
alternative is is a push configuration
and the push configuration is slightly
different the main difference is as with
a pull configuration you have a master
server where you actually put up the
instructions but unlike the pull
configuration where you have a client
installed on each of the services with a
push configuration you actually have no
client installed on the remote servers
you simply are pushing out the
configuration to those servers and
forcing a restructure or a fresh clean
installation in that environment
so anable is one of those second
environments where it's a push
configuration server and this contrasts
with other popular products like chef
and puppet which have a Master Slave um
architecture with a master server
connecting with a client on a remote
slave environment where you would then
be pushing out the updates with anel
you're pushing out the service and the
structure of the server to remote
hardware and you are just putting it
onto the hardware irrelevant of the
structure that's out there and there are
some significant advantages that you
have in that in that you're not having
to have the extra overhead weight of a
client installed on those remote servers
having to constantly communicate back to
the master environment so let's step
through the architecture that you would
have for an anible environment so when
you're setting up an anible environment
the first thing you want to do is have a
local machine and the local machine is
where you're going to have all of your
instruction and and really the power of
the control that you'd be pushing out to
the remote server so the local machine
is where you're going to be starting and
doing all of your work connected from
the local machine are all the different
nodes pushing out the different
configurations that you would set up on
the local machine the configurations
that you would write and you would write
those in code are within a module so you
do this on your local machine for
creating these modules and each of these
modules is actually consistent playbooks
the local machine also has a second job
and that job is to manage the inventory
of the nodes that you have in your
environment the local machine is able to
connect to each of the different nodes
that you would have in your Hardware
Network through SSH client so a secure
client let's dig into some of the
different elements within that
architecture and we're going to take a
first look at playbooks that you would
write and create for the anable
environments so the core of anable is
the Playbook this is where you create
the instructions that you write to
define the architecture of your Hardware
so the Playbook is really just a set of
instructions that configure the
different nodes that you have and each
of those set of instructions is written
in a language called yaml and this is a
standard language used for configuration
server environments did you know that
yaml actually stands for yaml a markup
language let's just a little tidbit to
hide behind your ear so let's have a
look or one of these playbooks it looks
like and here we have a sample yamamo
script that we've written so you start
off your yamama script with three dashes
and that integrates the start of a
script and then the script itself is
actually consistent of two distinct
plays at the top we have play one and
below that we have play two within each
of those plays we Define which nodes are
we targeting so here we have a web
server in the top play and in the second
play we have a database server that
we're targeting and then within each of
those server environments we have the
specific tasks that we're looking to
execute so let's step through some of
these tasks we have an install patchy
task we have a starter patchy task and
we have an install MySQL task and when
we do that we're going actually execute
a specific set of instructions and those
instructions can include installing
Apache and then setting the state of the
Apache environment or starting the
Apache environment and setting up and
running the MySQL environment so this
really isn't too complicated and that's
the really good thing about working with
Theo is it's really designed to make it
easy for you as an operations lead to be
able to configure the environments that
you want to consistently create so let's
take a step back though we have two
hosts we have web server and dat datase
server where do these names come from
well this takes us into our next stage
and the second part of working with
anible which is the inventory management
part of anible so the inventory part of
anible is where we maintain the
structure of our Network environment so
what we do here is part of the structure
and creating different nodes is we had
to create two different nodes here we
have a web server node and a database
server node and under web we server node
we actually have the names that were
actually pointed to specific machines
within that environment so now when we
actually write our scripts all we have
to do is refer to either web server or
database server and the different
servers will have the instructions from
the yamas script executed on them this
makes it really easy for you to be able
to just point to new services without
having to write out complex instructions
so let's have a look at how anible
actually works in real world so the real
world environment is that you would have
the anible software installed on a local
machine and then it connects to
different nodes within your network on
the local machine you'll have your first
your playbook which is the set of
instructions for how to set up the
remote nodes and then to identify how
you're going to connect to those nodes
you'll have an inventory we use secure
SSH connections to each of the servers
so we are encrypting the communication
to those servers we're able to grab some
basic facts on each server so we
understand how we can then push out the
Playbook to each server and configure
that server remotely the end goal is to
have an environment that is consistent
so this asks you a simple question what
are the major opportunities the anable
has over chef and puppet really like to
hear your answers in the comments below
pop them in there and we'll get back to
you and really want to hear how you feel
that anible is a stronger product or
maybe you think it's a weaker product as
it compares to other similar products in
the market here's the bonus we're going
to talk a little bit about anible Tower
so anible Tower is an extra product that
red hat created that really kind of puts
the cherry on the top of the ice cream
or is the icing and on your cake anable
by itself is a command line tool however
anable Tower is a framework that was
designed to access anible and through
the anible tower framework we now have
an easyto use guey this really makes it
easy for non-developers to be able to
create the environment that they want to
be able to manage in their devops plan
without having to constantly work with
the command prompt window so instead of
opening up terminal window or command
window and writing out complex
instructions only in text you can now
use drag and drop and mouse click
actions to be able to create your
appropriate playbooks inventories and
pushes for your nodes all right so we've
talked a lot about Ansel let's take a
look at a specific company that's using
anel today and in this example we're
going to look at hoot Suite now hoot
Suite if you've not already used that
their products and they have a great
product hoot is a social media
management system they are able to help
with you managing your pushes of social
media content across all of the popular
social media platforms they're able to
provide the analytics they're able to
provide the tools that marketing and
sales teams can use to be able to assess
a sentiment analysis of the messages
that are being pushed out really great
tool and very po popular but part of
their popularity drove a specific
problem straight to hoot Suite the
challenge they had at hotu is that they
had to constantly go back and rebuild
their server environment and they
couldn't do this continuously and be
consistent there was no standard
documentation and they had to rely on
pure memory to be able to do this
consistently imagine how complex this
could get as you're scaling up with a
popular product that now has tens of
thousands to hundreds of thousands of
users this is where ano what came in and
really helped the folks over at
HootSuite today the devops team at
HootSuite write out playbooks that have
Specific Instructions that Define the
architecture and structure of their
Hardware nodes and environments and are
able to do that as a standard product
instead of it being a problem in scaling
up their environment they now are able
to rebuild and create new servers in a
matter of seconds the bottom line is
anible has been able to provide hoot
Suite with it automation consistent
configuration and free out time from the
operations team so that instead of
managing servers they're able to provide
additional new value to the company a
very warm welcome to all our viewers I'm
Angeli from Simply learn and today I'll
be taking you you through a tutorial on
anible so anible is currently the most
trending and popular configuration
management tool and it's used mostly
under the devops approach so what will
you be learning today you learn why you
should use anible what exactly is anible
the anible architecture how anible works
the various benefits of anible and
finally we'll have a demo on the
installation of Apache or the httpd
package on our client systems we'll also
be hosting a very simple web page and
during this demo I'll also show you how
you can write a very simple playbook in
yamon and your inventory file so let's
begin why should you use anible let's
consider a scenario of an organization
where Sam is a system administrator Sam
is responsible for the company's
infrastructure a company's
infrastructure basically consists of all
its systems this could include your web
servers your database servers the
various repositories and and so on so as
a system administrator Sam needs to
ensure that all the systems are running
the updated versions of the software now
when you consider a handful of systems
this seems like a pretty simple task Sam
can simply go from system to system and
perform the configurations required but
that is not the case with an
organization is it an organization has a
very large infrastructure it could have
hundreds and thousands of systems so
here is where Sam's work gets really
difficult not only does it get tougher
Sam has to move from system to system
performing the same task over and over
again this makes Sam bored not just that
repeating the same task leaves no space
for Innovation and without any ideas or
innovation how does the system grow and
the worst of it all is manual labor is
prone to errors so what does Sam do well
here is where anable comes in use with
anable Sam can write simple quotes that
are deployed onto all all the systems
and configure them to the correct States
so now that we know why we should use an
let's look at what exactly is anible
anible is an IT engine that automates
the following tasks so first we have
orchestration orchestration basically
means bringing together of multiple
applications and ensuring an order in
which these are executed so for example
if you consider a web page that you
require to host this web page stores all
its values that it takes from the user
user into a database so the first thing
you must do is ensure that the system
has a database manager and only then do
you host your web page so this kind of
an order is very crucial to ensure that
things work right next an will automate
configuration management so
configuration management simply means
that all the systems are maintained at a
consistent desired State other tools at
automate configuration management
include puppet and Chef and finally
anible automates deployment deployment
simply means the deploying of
application onto your servers of
different environments so if you have to
deploy an application on 10 systems with
different environments you don't have to
manually do this anymore CU anible
automates it for you in fact anible can
also ensure that these applications or
the code are deployed at a certain time
or after regular intervals now that we
know what exactly anible is let's look
at anel's architecture anible has two
main compon compents you have the local
machine and you have your note or the
client machine so the local machine is
where the system administrator sits here
she installs anible here and on the
other end you have your node or the
client systems so in case of anible
there's no supporting software installed
here these are just the systems that
require to be configured and they are
completely controlled by the local
machine at your local machine you also
have a module a module is a collection
of your configuration files and in case
of anable these configuration files are
called playbooks playbooks are written
in yaml yaml stands for yaml ain't a
markup language and it is honestly the
easiest language to understand and learn
since it's so close to English we also
have the inventory the inventory is a
file where you have all your nodes that
require configuration mentioned and
based on the kind of configuration they
required they also group together so
later in the demo we'll have a look at
how the Playbook and the inventory is
written and that will probably make it
clearer so of course the local machine
needs to communicate with the client and
how is this done this is done through
SSH ssh is your secure shell which
basically provides a protected
Communication in an unprotected
environment okay so we saw the various
components of anible now how does anible
exactly work you have your local machine
on one end this is where you install
anible if you have gone through any
previous material on anible you would
have come acoss across the term
agentless often being associated with
this tool so this is what agentless
means you're installing anible only on
your local machine and there's no
supporting software or plug-in being
installed on your clients this means
that you have no agent on the other end
the local machine has complete control
and hence the term agentless another
term that you would come across with
anable is push configuration so since
the local machine has complete control
here it push PES the playbooks onto the
notes and thus it's called a push
configuration tool now the playbooks and
the inventory are written at the local
machine and the local machine connects
with the notes through the SSH client
this step here is optional but it's
always recommended to do so it's where
the facts are collected so facts are
basically the current state of the node
now all this is collected from the node
and sent to the local machine so when
the Playbook is executed the task
mentioned in the Playbook is compared
against the current status of the note
and only the changes that are required
to be made further are made and once the
playbooks are executed your nodes are
configured to the desired States so as I
mentioned before Anil is currently the
most trending tool in the market under
the configuration management umbrella so
let's have a look at the various
benefits of anible which gives it this
position well anible is agentless it's
efficient it's flexible simple it
important and provides automated
reporting how does it do all this let's
have a look at that agentless as I
already mentioned before you require no
supporting software or Plugin installed
on your node or the client system so the
master has complete control and
automatically this means that anable is
more efficient cuz now we have more
space in our client and notes systems
for other resources and we can get
anible up and running real quick anable
is also flexible so an infrastructure is
prone to change very often and anable
takes no amount of time to adjust to
these changes anable cannot get any
simpler with your playbooks written in a
language such as yaml which is as close
to English as you can possibly get IR
important basically means that if you
have a Playbook which needs to be run n
number of systems it would have the same
effect on all of these systems without
any side effect and finally we have
automated reporting so in case of anible
your playbook has number of tasks and
all these tasks are named so whenever
you run or execute your playbook it
gives a report on which tasks ran
successfully which failed which clients
were not reachable and so on all this
information is very crucial when you're
dealing with a very large infrastructure
and finally we reach the most exciting
part of our tutorial the Hands-On before
we move on to the actual handsone let me
just brief you through what exactly
we'll be doing so I'll be hosting two
virtual boxes both both Cent 7 Operating
Systems one would be my local machine
and other my node or the client machine
so on my local machine first I'll
install anible we then write the
inventory and the Playbook and then
simply deploy this Playbook on the
client machine there's just one thing
that we need to do is that we need to
check if the configurations that we
mentioned in our Playbook are made right
so we'll now begin our demo this is my
Oracle virtual box here I have my master
system which is the local machine and
this is the client machine so let's have
a look at these two machines this is my
client machine the terminal is open
right now so the client machine terminal
has a black background with white text
and the Master machine terminal has a
white background with black text just so
you can differentiate between the two so
we'll start at the Master machine the
first thing to do is we need to install
our anible so yum
install anible hyphen Y is the command
to do
so
so this might take some
time yeah so anable is installed the
next step we go to our host file so our
host file here is basically the
inventory it's where you'll specify all
your nodes in our case we just have one
node
that's the path to your host
file as you'll see everything here is
commented so just type in the group for
your client notes so I'm going to name
it anable
[Music]
clients and here we need to type the IP
address of a client machine so my client
machine's IP address is
192 168
2127 so before you come to this it's
advised that you check the IP address on
your client machine the simple command
for that is if config now once you type
the IP address put a space and here we
need to mention the username and the
password for our client so I'll be
logging in as the root
user so this is the
password and then the
user which is Root in my
case that's it now you can save this
file just clear the
screen next we move on to our Playbook
we need to write The
Playbook so the extension for our
Playbook is yml which stands for
yaml and as you can see here I have
already written my playbook but I'll
just explain to you how this is done so
a yaml file always begins with three
dashes this indicates the start of your
yaml
file now the first thing is you need to
give a name to the entire Playbook so I
have named it sample book host is
basically where this would be executed
so as we saw earlier in our inventory I
mentioned client group name as anable
clients so we use the same name
here the remote user is the user you'll
be using at your client so in my case
that's root and become true is basically
to indicate that you need to set your
privileges at rote so that's called a
privilege escalation now A playbook
consists of tasks so we have here three
tasks the first task I've named it to
install httpd so what we doing here is
we are installing our httpd package
which is basically the Apache server and
we're installing the most latest version
of it hence the state value is latest
the next task is running httpd so for
the service the name is httpd because
that's the service we need to start
running and the state is started our
next task is creating content so this is
the part where we are creating our web
page so copy because this is the file
that will be created at the client the
content will be welcome and the
destination of the file will be V www
HTML index.html as you know this is like
a default path that we use to store all
our HTML files now as you can see here
there's quite a lot of indentation and
when it comes to yaml although it's very
simple to write and very easy to read
the indentation is very crucial
so the first Dash here represents the
highest stage that is the name of the
Playbook and all the dashes under task
are slightly shifted towards the right
so if you have two dashes at the same
location they basically mean that they
are siblings so the priority would be
the same so to ensure that all your
tasks are coming under the tasks label
make sure they are not directly under
name so yeah that's pretty much it so
when you write your yaml file the
language is pretty simple very readable
indentation absolutely necessary make
sure all your spaces are correctly
placed we can now save this
file next thing we need to check if the
syntax of our yaml file is absolutely
right because that's very crucial so the
command to check the syntax of the yaml
file is anable
Playbook the name of your
playbook
syntax
check so we have no syntax errors which
is why the only output you receive is
sample. yml which is the name of your
playbook so our Playbook is ready to be
executed the command to execute the
Playbook is anle
Playbook and the name of your
playbook so our playbooks executed as
you can see here Gathering facts that's
where all the facts of the note that's
the present state of the note is
collected and sent to the local machine
so it's basically to check that if the
configuration changes that we are about
to make is already made so it's not made
we do not have the httpd package
installed on our node so this is the
first change that's made also if it's
not installed of course it's not running
that's a second change that's made so
it's put into the Run running State and
a final task which is create content is
under the okay State this means that the
contents already present in the client
machine so I made it this way so that
you can at least see the different
states that's present so over here we
have okay four so four things are all
fine the facts are gathered two things
are changed and one is already present
two changes are
made zero clients are unreachable and
zero tasks have failed so this is the
documentation that I was referring to
previously that anible provides
automatically and is very useful as you
can see so our next step we need to just
check on our client machine if all the
changes that we desired are made so
let's move to our
client so this is my client machine so
to check this since we are installing
the httpd package and hosting a web page
the best way to do it is open your
browser and type in Local
Host so there you go your Apache server
is installed and your web page is
hosted so let's go through the scenario
of why you'd want to use these tools so
let's meet Tim he's our system
administrator and Tim is a happy camper
putting and working on all of the
systems in his network but what happens
if a system fails if there's a fire a
server goes down well Tim knows exactly
what to do he can fix that fire really
easily the problems become really
difficult for Tim however if multiple
servers start failing particularly when
you have large and expanding networks so
this is why Tim really needs to have a
configuration management tool and we
need to now decide what what would be
the best tool for him because
configuration management tools can help
make Tim look like a superstar all he
has to do is configure the right codes
that allows him to push out the
instructions on how to set up each of
the servers quickly effectively and at
scale all right let's go through the
tools and see which ones we can use the
tools that we're going to go through are
Chef puppet anpal and salt stacks and we
have videos on most of the software and
services that you can go and view to get
an overview or a deep dive in how those
products work so let's go and get to
know our contestants so our first
contestant is Chef and Chef is a tool
that allows you to configure very large
environment it allows you to scale very
effectively across your entire ecosystem
and infrastructure Chef is by default an
open-source code um and one of the
things that you find as a consistent
metaphor for the tools that we recommend
on simply learn is to use open-source
code the code itself is actually written
in the language of Ruby and Earline and
it's really designed for heterogeneous
infrastructures that are looking for a
mature solution the way that Chef works
is that you write recipes that are
compiled into cookbooks and those
cookbooks are the definition of how you
would set up a node and a node is a
selection of servers that you have
configured in a specific way so for
instance you may have Apache Linux
servers running or you may have a MySQL
server running or you may have a python
server running and Chef is able to
communicate back and forth between the
nodes to understand what nodes are being
impacted and need to have instructions
sent out to them to correct that impact
you can also send instructions from the
server to the nodes to make a
significant update or a minor update so
there's great communication going back
and forth if we look at the pros and and
cons the pros for Chef is that there is
a significant following for chef and
that has resulted in a very large
collection of recipes that allow you to
be able to quickly stand up environments
there's no need for you to have to learn
complex recipes the first thing you
should do is go out and find the recipes
that are available it integrates with
Git really well and provides for really
good strong Version Control some of the
conso are really around the learning
speed it takes to go from beginner user
with Chef to being an expert there is a
considerable amount of learning that has
to take place and it's compounded by
having to learn Ruby as the programming
language and the main server itself
doesn't really have a whole lot of
control it's really dependent on the
communication throughout the whole
network all right let's look at our
second Contender puppet and puppet is
actually in many ways very similar to
Chef there are some differences but
again puppet is designed to be able to
support very large heterogeneous
organization it is also built with Ruby
and uses DSL for writing manifests so
there are some strong similarities here
to Chef as with a chef there is a Master
Slave infrastructure with puppet and you
have a master server that has the
manifests that you put together in a
single catalog and those catalogs are
then pushed out to the clients over an
SSL connection some of the pro
with puppet is that as with Chef there
is a really strong Community around
puppet and there's just a great amount
of information and support that you can
get right out of the gate it is a very
well-developed reporting mechanism that
makes it easier for you as an
administrator to be able to understand
your infrastructure one of the cons is
that you have to really be good at
learning Ruby again as with sha you know
the more advanced tasks really need to
have those Ruby skills and as with Chef
the server also doesn't have much
control so let's look at our third
Contender here anable and so anable is
slightly different it is the way that
anible works is that it actually just
pushes out the instructions to the
server environment there isn't a client
server or Master Slave environment where
anible would be communicating backwards
and forwards with its infrastructure it
is merely going to push that instr
instuctions out the good news is that
the instructions are written in yaml and
yaml stands for yaml a markup language
yaml is actually pretty easy to learn if
you know XML and XML is pretty easy if
you know XML you're going to get yaml
really well as does work very well on
environments where the focuses are
getting servers up and running really
fast it's very very responsive and can
allow you to move quickly to get your
infrastructure up quick very fast when
we're talking second and minutes here
really really quick uh so again the way
that anable works is that you put
together a Playbook and an inventory or
you have a Playbook so the way that
anable works is that you have a Playbook
and the Playbook it then goes against
the inventory of servers and will push
out the instructions for that Playbook
to those servers so some of the pros
that we have for anible we don't need to
have an agent install on the remote
nodes and servers it makes it easier for
the configuration yaml is really easy to
learn you can get up to speed and get
very proficient with the ymo quickly the
actual performance once you actually
have your infrastructure up and running
is less than other tools that we have on
our list now I do have to add a provisor
this is a relative less it's still very
fast it's going to be a lot faster than
individuals manually standing up servers
but it's just not as fast as some of the
other tools that we have on this list
and yaml itself as a language while it's
easy to learn it's not as powerful as
Ruby Ruby will allow you to do things
that at an advanced level that you can't
do easily with the Amo so let's look at
our final Contender here salt stack so
salt stack is a CLI based tool it means
that you will have to get your command
line tools out or your terminal window
out so you can actually manage the
entire environment via salt sack the
instructions themselves are based on
python but you can actually write them
in yaml or CSL which is really
convenient and as a product it's really
designed for environments that want to
scale quickly and be very resilient uh
the way that salt snap works is that you
have a master environment that pushes
out the instructions to what they call
grains which is your network and so
let's step through some of the pros and
cons that we have here with salt stag so
s is very easy to use once it's up and
running it has a really good reporting
me mechanism that makes your job as an
operator in your devops environment much
much easier the actual setup though is a
little bit tougher than some of the
other tools and and it's getting easier
with the newer releases but it's just a
little bit tougher and related to that
is that sorts stack is fairly late in
the game when it comes to actually
having a graphical user interface for
being able to create and manage your
environment other tools such as anible
have actually had a UI environment for
quite some time all right so we've gone
through all four tools let's see how
they all stack up next to each other so
let the race begin let's start with the
first stage architecture so the
architecture for most of our
environments is a server client
environment so for Chef puppet and salt
snack so very similar architecture there
the one exception is anible which is a
client Only Solution so you're pushing
out the instructions from a server and
pushing them out into your netork networ
and there isn't a client environment
there isn't a two-way communication back
to that main client for what's actually
happening in your network so let's talk
about the next stage ease of setup so we
look at the four tools there is one tool
that really stands out for ease of setup
and that is anle it is going to be the
easiest tool for you to set up and if
you're new to having these types of
tools in your environment you may want
to start with anible just to try out and
see how easy is to create automated
configuration before looking at other
tools now and so with that said Chef
puppet and scec aren't that hard to set
up either and you'll find there's
actually some great instructions on how
to do that setup in the online community
let's talk about the languages that you
can use in your configuration so we have
two different types of language with
both chef and answerable being
procedural and that they actually
specify at how you're actually supposed
to do the task in your instructions with
puppet and salt stack it's decorative
where you specify only what to do in the
instructions let's talk about
scalability which tools scale the most
effectively and as you can imagine all
of these tools are designed for
scalability that is the driver for these
kind of tools you want them to be able
to scale to massive organizations what
do the management tools look like for
our four contenders so again we have a
two-way split with anible and sort stack
of management tools are really easy to
use you're going to love using them
they're just fantastic to use with
puppet and Chef the management tools are
much harder to learn and they do require
that you learn some either the puppet
DSL or the Ruby DSL to be able to be a
true master in that environment but what
does interoperability look like again as
you'd imagine with the similar to
scalability interoperability with these
products is very high in all four cases
now let's talk about Cloud availability
this is increasingly becoming more
important for organizations as they move
rapidly onto cloud services well both
anable and Sal stack have a big fail
here neither of them are available in
the most popular Cloud environments and
puppet and Chef are actually available
in both Amazon and AIA uh we've actually
just haven't had a chance to update our
Chef link here but Chef is now available
on Azure as well as Amazon so what does
communication look like with all of our
four tools so the communication is
slightly different with them Chef has
its own knife Tool uh whereas puppet
uses SSL secure sockets layer and anible
and sort stack use secure socket hashing
SSH as their communication tool bottom
line all four tools are very secure in
their communication so who wins well
here's the reality all four tools are
very good and it's really dependent on
your capabilities and the type of
environment that you're looking to
manage that will determine which of
these four tools you should use the
tools themselves are open source so go
out and experiment with them there's a
lot of videos our team has done a ton of
videos on these tools and so feel free
to find out other tools that we have
then covered so you can learn very
quickly how to use them but consider the
requirements that you have and consider
the capabilities of your team if you
have Ruby developers or you have someone
on your team that knows Ruby your
ability to choose a broader set of tools
becomes much more interesting if however
you're new to coding then you may want
to consider yamel based tools again the
final answer is going to be up to you
and we'll be really interested on what
your DEC decision is please post in the
comments below hi guys welcome to this
video on the interview questions of
configuration management tools chef
anible and puppet Chef is a
configuration management tool written in
Ruby and erlang which provides
continuous deployment increases system
robustness and provides Cloud
integration anible is another
open-source software tool for
provisioning configuration management
and application deployment and puppet is
a configuration management tool that can
also be used as a deployment tool and
implements infrastructure as a code in
this video we have compiled the most
important interview questions of
configuration management tools chef
anible and puppet that you might face in
a devops interview so without further
Ado let's get started so let's just get
into the first section which is
configuration management so one of the
questions that you'll get asked right
away is why do you have slsl
certificates used for Chef really
fundamentally your immediate answer
should be security SSL provides for a
very high level of private security and
private and public key pairing this
really is essential to ensure that you
have a secure environment through out
your entire network the second part
should be that if you're using SSL and
you're using the private public key
model within SSL you're able to
guarantee the systems on your network
that the chef that you'll be able to
validate that the nodes within your
network that Chef is validating against
actually are the real nodes themselves
not imposters so you will also be asked
um some questions um such as the
following which of the following
commands would you use to stop or
disable the HTTP servers when the system
boots and you'll typically get four
responses and there'll be hash systemctl
disable htpd do service or is it system
disable htpd do service system disable
httpd or the final option which is
system CTL disable httpd dos service
your answer should be the first one
which is # system CLD disable
httpservice so Chef comes with a series
of tools that allow it to function
effectively and one of the tools that
you're going to be asked about is what
is Test Kitchen and Test Kitchen is
essentially a command line tool that
allows you to be able to test out your
cookbook before you actually deploy to a
real node so some of the commands that
you would use are for instance if you
want to create an instance of Test
Kitchen you would do kitchen create if
you want to destroy an incense after you
created it you do kitchen destroy and if
you want to be able to combine multiple
instances you would do kitchen converge
so a question you'll get is around Chef
is how does Chef apply differ from Chef
client so fundamentally the difference
between them is that Chef apply will
valid Val the recipe that you're working
on whereas Chef client looks to apply
and validate the entire cookbook that's
run in your server environment so one is
focused on the recipe and the other is
focused on the entire cookbook so there
are some differences when you're working
with different command lines so for
instance when you're working with a
puppets and you're working with one
version of puppet and you want to do
what is the command to sign a requested
certificate the top example here is for
puppet version 2.7 whereas the lower
option here is for puppet version 3 and
something to bear in mind when you're
going through your interview process is
that the tools that are used within a
continuous integration continuous
delivery devops model do vary and so you
want to be able to talk knowledgeably
about the different versions of the
tools so that when you're talking to
your interviewer you're able to show the
Deep knowledge that you have which open
source or Comm Community tools do you
use to make puppet more powerful and
essentially this question is going to be
asking you to look beyond the core
Foundation of puppet itself and so the
three options you have is being able to
track configurations with jir which you
should be doing anyway but it's a great
way to be able to clearly communicate
the work that's been done with puppet a
Version Control can be extended with G
and then the changes should be passed
through Jenkins so the three tools you
want to be looking at integration with J
git and Jenkins so what are the
resources in pubit well fundamentally
there are four the resources are a basic
unit of any configuration management
tool they are the features of the node
they are the written catalog and the
execution of the catalog on a node so as
we dig deeper into puppet one of the
things that you are likely to be asked
regarding puppet is what is a class in
puppet and so a class in puppet is
really the name blocks in your manifest
that contain the various configurations
and this can include Services files and
packages and we have on the screen here
an example of what a class would look
like when you write it out and you may
want to memorize just one class don't
memorize just a whole set of classes
just memorize one the person that's
interviewing you is just really looking
for someone who has a working knowledge
they're not looking for you to have
memorized complete massive class classes
but having one small class to be able to
illustrate the experience you have is
extremely valuable to the interviewer
particularly if it's a technical
interview so as we move into anable one
of the things that you're going to be
asked around anable is what is anable
role so a rooll is an independent block
of tasks and variable files and
templates embedded with inside of the
Playbook so example we have here on the
screen actually shows you one role
within a Playbook and in this role it is
to install Tom Cat on a node again as
with previous question within puppet of
a class it's probably good to have
memorize just one or two roles so you
can talk knowledgeably about anable when
you're having your interview so when
you're working with anable when should
you be using the curly brackets and so
just as a frame of reference uh there's
often two different ways that these kind
of brackets are referred to now they're
either referred to as French brackets or
curly brackets ET either way and what
you'll be wanting to ask is when would
you use these specific types of brackets
within an support and really the answer
comes down into two things one is that
it makes it easier to distinguish
strings and undefined variables and the
second is for putting together
conditional statements when you are
actually using variables and the example
we have here is this prints the value of
and we have Fu and we have to then put
in the variable conditional statement of
fu is defined as something so what is
the best way to make content reusable
and redistributable with anable and
there's really essentially three the
first is to include a subm module or
another file in your playbook the second
is to import an improvement of an
include which ensures that a file is
added only once and then the third is
roles to manage the tasks within the
Playbook so a question you will be asked
is provide a differences between anable
and puppets so if we look at anel it's a
very easy agentless installation it's
based on python you can configure it
with yaml and there are no support for
Windows in contrast puppet is an agent
based installation it's written in Ruby
the configuration files are written in
DSL and it has support on all popular
operating systems so we dig deeper into
the actual architecture and it has a
much more simple architecture and it's
definitely a pushon architecture and in
contrast to puppet it's a more
complicated but more sophisticated
architecture where you're able to have a
complete environment managed by the
puppet architect so here we wrap up the
answerable course for beginers if you
have any questions please feel free to
add it in the comment section and our
experts will be happy to help you do
like share and subscribe to Simply learn
to never miss any updates from us till
then thanks for watching staying ahead
in your career requires continuous
learning and upskilling whether you're a
student aiming to learn today's top
skills or a working professional looking
to advance your career we've got you
covered explore our impressive catalog
of certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to ner up and get certified click
here